[Music]
welcome everyone
to a webinar step into the sunlight
project management after covered 19.
it's part of our step into the sunlight
series of webinars
on how to emerge from lockdown
and our speaker today is tim jerome
thought leader in project management i'm
your host stuart creek
a marketing manager here at simply learn
so with that i'm going to introduce
tim trump tim why don't i let you go
ahead
and describe yourself
thank you very much stuart good day
everyone i hope you are doing all well
and enjoying yourself it's a beautiful
uh early morning here on my part of the
world it's a little overcast we have not
seen
rain for weeks and weeks and weeks but
we can still go out for walks and play
in our gardens right
[Music]
i'm tim i have been teaching project
management for over 16 years
and i've been doing projects in project
management for a
little longer i started 1992 1993 when
my supervisor said
congratulations tim you're a project
manager go out
and be successful and
i learned and i grew one of the smartest
things i did
was listen to everybody around me when i
was managing my projects
i listened to the teams i listened to my
peers i listened to my
manager and i listened to my end users
when i was teaching i listened to
all of my students my students are the
wise ones
if there's anything that comes from my
mouth that's close to wisdom
it's the other people who've influenced
me and i figured out that
what they were talking about was great
and i continue that tradition
i do speak a lot out in public you can
find me out on the internet all the time
i listen to a lot of my peers too
and there are many changes in project
management
and projects but my biggest joy
is helping and supporting you who are
going to be
taking project management and refining
it
and growing it in the next two to three
decades
these are exciting decades yes they're
challenging
yes they are surprises and that's what
we're going to talk about
surprises have good sides and they also
have bad sides and we'll look at both of
those
so the first thing we want to look at
is um what is project management turning
into how is it going to change well
we have to be careful with this because
we have to remember
that project management is all about
change and thank you for that question
by the way
um we'll be more than happy to answer
those in a bit
[Music]
when i started in projects and project
management in
major corporations back in 2000
it was obvious that i went to the
customer side i worked with my clients i
engaged
with them directly as i progressed
through
2005-2007 all of a sudden
my teams were spread across the planet
and so i gradually transitioned to a
um remote and a distributed environment
it was difficult
i had to learn things like engaging and
motivating
through a camera and through a
microphone like we're doing now
now that we have been forced to be in
our homes
companies have said well we have no
choice we must move forward
and so all of a sudden people have been
doing this
and so leading and directing and
managing work
became natural and people have learned
how to work as groups and individuals
and that's the tough part
okay project management is a lot of
measuring inspecting
and analyzing and making decisions and
you can do that wherever you are on the
planet right you can attach a
excel spreadsheet or maybe a powerpoint
or a word
and and it works very well to actually
collect information and gain consensus
as long as everybody's engaged
and that's the trick how do i engage
and how do i keep people committed and
obligated
and that's due to how we build our
relationships
i want to explore this a little further
too
and and this is where things get really
important
it's all about the relationship
we knew this we we've known this
everyone has known this
you learn schedules and cost and risk
and all the technical components
all of a sudden in two or three years of
managing projects that's pretty easy
you can almost automate that which is
scary
does that mean i'm out of a job no it
means i get to focus on the more
important part which is the people part
and if you observe um
project management institute uh there
by the way by the way i teach project
management and i
teach preparation for the project
management professional
pmp credential it's one of the more
influential project management
credentials and what it does
is it gives you a certain
confidence that says tim or anybody else
who has this
has a level of expertise
in project management so you can go out
and do this and it's owned
and it's controlled by the project
management
institute a non-profit organization that
was created about
1969 to pull
a group of peers together like you and
me
to standardize what we know as good
project management and so they've been
doing this all along
now to get back to what we're talking
about
leadership and management all of a
sudden became
really important and it becomes
important for you when you're about five
or ten minutes
ten years into your career and this is
where you actually start
developing what we know as leadership
right
being able to motivate people find
some way to connect their personal
experience
with the experience of uh
of good work right give them a reason to
do work well and
influence right make it easy
for them to do their work and this is
what you do as a project manager you
make sure
that the team does the work well
now what's happened
is a whole group of project managers
have learned that you can do this over
the internet you don't
have to do it face to face it's better
face to face it really is
you know you create you know you engage
more you get to read the body language
more
but you can do it if you learn
a few behaviors that work really well
second of all you're able to understand
the
unknown and i've actually seen and
observed this a lot i've been
talking to a lot of people who do
projects and project management in
healthcare
and in software development and in
construction and they all come up with
the same thing
all of a sudden risk is a conversation
topic right
what might happen we never expected
covet we expected a lot of things to
happen in 2020
but we never expected a pandemic and so
the trigger of one pandemic causes
people like leaders
high project managers say
you know what if this could actually
bring us to our knees
what else could possibly happen and
that's the job of a leader and a manager
preparing the environment
so that these things don't disturb
progress
[Music]
i find a lot more curiosity in
estimation of risk an estimation
of error what if we're wrong right
people are a little more cautious in
doing work
at the same time business is saying
we must change we must modify so you
have
an interesting dynamic you have
business on one side creating this type
of attention we must progress we must
figure out how to do business better you
know we we have a lot of questions about
whether
you know we need to bring people in now
or later and we have project managers
saying well
let's slow down a little bit and right
in the middle
there's that tension and it's that
tension that creates the innovation
so we're having a lot of this risk
and not second guessing but analysis
that's going on
that's really not just appropriate but
it's embraced
we're doing what we're doing and it's
being accepted
which is great now communication
is what's critical to make this happen
leadership is all about relationships
it's about you and me you know learning
how we work together
and we observe each other over time and
we learn to predict
behaviors right this is what's called
trust
and you cannot do that over email
now we thought we couldn't do it from
the privacy of our homes
but necessity is the mother of invention
isn't it
and so we've learned that
yeah we can get it done and it does take
trust
and it takes constant interaction
i found myself and a lot of my other
peers and
articles are saying that you we're
tending to reach out more and interact
instead of just waiting for things to
happen
you know you cannot predict that
um you're going to get emails to tell
you where we're going next
as a project manager we can't wait
we have to be the ones that reach out
and engage
now that was so up to about september
october and november and then in january
and february
it became even more important and so
even though we know that meetings get in
the way of work
we're actually saying maybe meetings are
not just to get work done
maybe meetings are also there
for us to create and enrich
relationships so we're having this
communication we're having more meetings
and it's actually working
that's the funny thing we um back in
2005
i was listening to executives say you
know we have to get rid of meetings
and we need everybody in the room and
we need to do this face to face and so
we have these
two again these two dynamics going on
and all of a sudden
in the face of necessity
with the lockdown with everybody
physically remote
um we're having a sense
that we need to move forward and and
live with a new structure now right now
is the time where people are coming from
out of their houses and starting to go
back to work and we don't know what's
going to happen next
some parts of the world are going to go
back into lockdown
others are going to start working
together
and we're going to continue to observe
this but i expect
that businesses are going to embrace
these tools and these experiences
especially
project managers project management is
beautiful
it's a lot of it is crisis management
and what works right
what worked when when we were locked
down zoom
and zoom didn't just work for um
meetings did it
it worked for book clubs it worked for
talking
to your family and your pets right and
so
this is the way project management and
project managers look at this
that's what we know as innovation and we
can expect more of this to happen
a couple couple things that that jumped
out at me from that
uh discussion tim um a man named nazi
nicholas taylor
talks about something he calls black
swans
called them that because before
europeans had
gotten to australia it was
assumed that all swans are white but
then they found a species of swan in
australia that's black
something they'd never seen before and
so he calls any event that
has never happened before or has
happened so rarely that
people forget it could happen calls that
a black swan and that's what this
this pandemic is you know what's
fascinating about this stuart
if you do study these black swans
they realize these black swans were
always
there they it wasn't that they just
appeared they didn't magically appear
they'd already been there
but nobody had really noticed them as
important and and like i said in 2004
2004 16 years ago i was teaching up to
50 people in my project management
classes
remotely and i was getting reasonably
good marks even though the technology
was
horrible but we were actually preparing
50 people at a time
inside my company using this remote
management
um and it was always there
and and you don't notice the black swans
you don't look at them in forecast
you look at them in retrospective and
that's where you see the great patterns
um that's a brilliant that's that's a
brilliant observation stewart
the other the other thing i wanted to
mention is that there was a quote
from a former defense secretary of the
united states and
people made fun of him a little bit but
it's it's a very true thing that he said
he said there are
known knowns the things you know you
know there are unknown
knowns the things you know but you don't
know you know them
then there are the known unknowns the
things you know that you don't know
and finally the unknown unknowns the
things that you don't know and you don't
know that you don't know them
yeah yeah there was a there was an
economist named zuichi
um who talked about unknowable
unknowns there's no way we can predict
them
and in statistics um we have
something called estimation error
epsilon right it's a variable that says
you are always going to be off
now we don't like project managers when
we're not project managers right
because they say hold on a minute let's
pump the brakes and let's think they
also
say what if we're wrong what if we're
wrong
what if we're wrong and a project
manager is a broken record
but we understand now
what they mean and and it's funny
because this is human behavior and we
can talk about this later
but human behavior says until something
is personal
it's on a spreadsheet and it's a number
but when it's personal it's
visceral and i have a close experience
you know we all
see the news and we all see the articles
that say until i got
covered it wasn't real until i realized
how serious it is i didn't want to wear
a mask please everybody wear a mask
and this is just natural human behavior
it's not that it's bad it's not good
either it's just a fact
and so with these unknowable unknowns
we are the thorns in the side
now at this point
in our progress in in the way
work is getting done project managers
are
in a very uh well-liked position
it's going to swing back and it's going
to swing back to where
executives are going to say you're
holding me back project manager and the
team's going to say you're holding me
back project manager
but that's all right maybe that's not so
bad
maybe it's us being able to
actually figure out how everything
fits together and that's and that's the
role of a project manager the divine
integrator
and it's not the project manager to be
you know observed and set up on a
pedestal
that's not where leaders belong leaders
belong
in making the hard decisions and saying
things and bringing things up
people don't like um this is
this is the beautiful thing humanity is
frustrating people are frustrating
and at the same point they are the
saving grace
one of my favorite movie quotes is uh
from an
obscure movie called herald and mod and
uh
maud says i love people they're my
species
it's time to move to the next question
what will the new normal of project
management look like
um that's a good question and and you
think about it right
um we teach in our classes project
management
is where i don't sit at my desk all the
time
right i sit at my desk and i get my
numbers straight
but then my numbers say hey there's
something interesting over here
i have to look at that and so ninety
percent of my time
is spent on ensuring good communication
which means i'm communicating
i'm changing how i'm communicating and
i'm
also uh making sure that the
communication is effective
so it's all going to be about
relationships and this is what we're
finding
more and more and more people are
gravitating away
from you know the spreadsheets it's not
that the spreadsheets are not necessary
we're still doing them
but we're focusing right now on
relationships now you can look at that
in two aspects right
number one just like the rest of the
world we're frustrated we're
angry and we're being isolated from our
friends and our coworkers
and so we will be reaching out on a
regular basis but
then again it's the job of a project
manager to understand the details
and have the data that we can turn into
information and so
we're going to be actually using our
communication
in the way that we were taught more
effectively and more and more and more
reaching out making sure that our
co-workers and their peers are feeling
safe
and comfortable as well as the progress
and and that's the role of the the
leader and we saw this again
back in 2015 that was a result of
surveys from the project management
institute
and they said they said
um you're gonna have to double down
project managers professional
development for the next two decades is
going to be around leadership
and it's going to be around business if
you understand leadership in businesses
you stand a greater chance
at retention at work because more and
more things are going to be automated
they didn't realize that things were
going to
happen like you know pandemics and
other things that disturb work but it's
a great advantage that we actually
started focusing more and more on this
in our classes and our training material
and education material
introducing the project managers from
2015
into more advanced leadership and
management and that's what we're going
to be doing
and and again the the other part that
has actually been looking at is the
business part you know
the there are different words that you
may hear being used
the business acumen right business
knowledge and expertise
business context the in the environment
around projects and project management
and pmi
project management institute back in
2015 said
we have to do this right and we talked
about how critical it was
to capture data and use
formal data analysis and that resonated
in 2015 with the release of the talent
triangle right
leadership business and technical
project management that's the excel
and the word and the powerpoint and then
in 2017 the project management body of
knowledge said look everyone
you're going to have to invest even more
in data analysis
you're going to need data scientists
you're going to need
business advisors or and business
analysts
you're going to be part of not just the
project success but the impact of the
project you're you're
you're contingent on ensuring business
success
which is exciting right it's exciting to
have that role as project manager but at
the same time
it's a huge amount of accountability and
i hear from my students
but tim i don't have authority
i i'm assigned this project but i don't
have the job title and i don't have
anything to show except for a credential
this is where leadership comes in and
and this is the beautiful thing
introducing the concept that you can
acquire
a set of skills called leadership
that you can learn that actually
give you leadership you can learn for
yourself
how to lead and this bunch
of knowledge is actually being
really embraced not just on mayan
students
but you can see it all over uh youtube
right
a lot of influencers in the business
realm
are talking about that you know you're
talk listening to
ryan holiday you're listening to simon
cynic
and it's not just now okay um there's
two big players um in
uh really big players
in business and quality
and economics and business decision
makers
um you have joseph duran you have
philip kirby and quality and then you
have
w.e deming right and i've been reading
w.e deming for the last five to seven
years i've been reading
peter drucker who was a business advisor
and consultant
for a long time and there's another guy
by the name of thomas j
peters he he came out of
one of the big eight consulting groups
now
peter drucker and w.e deming are
fascinating
and they did their homework and they
actually said the same thing in the 21st
century
management is going to have to change
things are going to be rapidly changing
quicker we have
automation we have globalization of
corporations
we have periods of economic
decline in economic gaining and they
were saying all this and management has
to approach
work and business differently now peter
drucker even goes
further and peter drucker says
we're not going to be skills-based
workers
we're going to be knowledge workers
because all the skills can be automated
right and and we've seen this anyway um
a lot of the work and and the jobs of
people have been slowly declining
and it's frightening because all of a
sudden you wake up in the middle of
night
you realize not only is my skill
redundant but even if i
plan and develop a skill for something
five years from now who's to tell me
that skill is going to be relevant even
then
so i what i'm doing right now is totally
irrelevant so
we've had to look at how do i
prepare people and how do i
think how people are going to have to
work
as we further and further automate our
lives and business
and that's where we get into knowledge
workers and
right now knowledge workers that term is
this great
great thing that we that we talk about
but we really don't understand
um you can see this back uh
though it and and this is what's really
interesting
because we've been talking about this
for millennia
we can go back to about oh
200 bc and we look at the great
philosophers
and they say don't come to me asking me
what to do
i want to help you learn how to think
and that's what education's job is right
now
it's not to give you a bunch of facts
and figures but help you
be on your feet and thinking
go ahead stuart i was just going to say
that
you know it's the job of educators
education in general to tell you
or to teach you how to think not what to
think but
how to think and
that's sometimes a controversial point
but
if you know how to think and how to how
to
look at problems analyze them
um look at them from multiple directions
then you're much better equipped
to solve those problems than if you've
learned
a step-by-step approach like a recipe
for how to do something or how to think
about something
this is tricky this is really tricky i'm
gonna i'm gonna
uh stay on this slide for a couple
minutes because
this is the challenge for project
management
it's the challenge for all managers okay
first of all companies are in business
to make money
right and they need to make money
constantly and consistently
so they have to have repetition and they
have to have
predictable outcomes okay so things have
to be in stasis
but companies also need to progress
they need innovation we have a dilemma
here don't we
not only that but we have a dilemma
between the people who are doing the
work
and the executive and the executive says
it has to go in this direction
and the workers say but
work is telling me it has to be done
that way
and so we're getting back to that
crucible i was talking about
an incredible amount of heat an
incredible amount of tension
and what we need is some governor
some agent that actually can keep that
pressure
and that heat from getting too much and
keep it from getting too
little so that we can be able to take
the
iron of what our work is from a
day-to-day basis
and turn it into steel and that's not
just the job
of executive management they're the
vision
it's not just the job of the worker
they're the progress it's somehow we all
come together
and you're exactly right stuart we
have to learn to be comfortable saying
i'm not right and i'm not wrong
you're not right and you're not wrong we
have a bunch of facts and figures
and i'm more interested in getting the
best result
not my result now
in leadership training
[Laughter]
this becomes a mantra
but how many of us are formally trained
in management this is the crux of
project management
you become a project manager
accidentally because you're really good
at a skill
and then you learn how to get people
together with your skills and do it well
as a group
and all of a sudden congratulations
you're a manager
and we have to actually
integrate this not just in a 35
hour project management training
environment but this
needs to be something that's discussed
at the group level at the organization
level at the business level
and the cultural and societal level
because
there is going to be a time when
all of the spreadsheets all of the
management of work
is going to be education it's going to
be automated
it's going to be managed
by numbers and facts and figures that
will eventually do it faster than people
but what's left over
it's the people and so what do we have
left over
it's not just you know a bunch of robots
in a factory
it's negotiation it's influence
it's creating this daily crucible where
everybody says
yes there's pressure yes there's heat
but we trust each other you have an open
mind
i have an open mind and this is the
this is what we do now this is the role
of project management
is to actually say let's pump the brakes
a little bit
here let's add a little bit of uh
of uh analysis and let's get to a point
where we can agree
it's not just schedule and cost
and risk and we're going to be
continuing this and over the next four
or five generations
this is going to be further and further
integrated
now there's other things that are
happening around
project management it's again the
further integration of concepts like
agile and we can talk about that if we
want
um the the the new ways of doing
projects and there's other movements
in project and project management and
the tools are always growing and
changing
but it's the human factor that's
continue
going to continue to be the
collaborative
component now
i think i've answered the next slide and
let's see what i wrote here
go ahead no i think that that
you know you've gone into some really
fascinating areas but like you said
it sets up the basis for um
what is the new um area of focus what
are the new areas of focus for for
project management as we come out of
this this lockdown so let's
there's going to be greater opportunity
for project management
and seeing what happened
after world war ii and seeing what
happened
after the great pandemic of 1918
and seeing what happened after
the fall of the bronze age and seeing
what happened
after the black death in the western
europe 1340
1350 and 60
there's going to be opportunities
in commerce and business okay there's
two things that run a society and keep
societies functioning communication
and commerce right and um
there's an opportunity for project
management
project management has always been
critical in business
but with a trained and
a confident leader and
manager part of the discussion
of where do we go now should we do this
project
or should we do this we have an
opportunity as long as we understand
how business makes the decision-making
if if we're talking just like executives
they're going to start asking us
questions and they're going to ask us
questions like
what do you think about this product
what do you think about that
product can you bring together two or
three teams and help us do this so
there's there's going to be exploration
into new revenue streams
and and again business is constantly
doing this all the time
but there's an opportunity for us to
step up and participate in that
discussion more
um as we move away if i could just
uh interject a kind of example that's
that may sound trivial but it's it's not
it's
um here
in the united states there have been
episodes of people not being able to get
some certain basic things like uh flour
for baking or
or toilet roll or that type of thing
because of panic buying and at the same
time there are
restaurants that were unable to
have people come in to dine but they had
access to industrial suppliers
for those staple goods and
we've seen some restaurants
shift their business models so that not
only do they deliver
meals that they prepare but they also
allow you to order
you know five pounds of flour and
four or five rolls of toilet paper and
have those delivered because they have
access to the
supply chain that consumers don't
so it's it sounds like a trivial example
but it's the difference between
life and death for those restaurants and
it provides a service
that at least for the time being
consumers can use to to fill in a a real
gap in their lives
there's something else that's really
awesome here
um we had a great depression in the
1930s in the united states
and things were so bad for so long
that this flower that people bought
um they took the cotton cloth and made
clothes out of them
yeah yeah the the sacks the cotton or
the sacks that the flower came in that
people would
would then reuse the those cloth sacks
so these flower companies
turned around and they put
floral and other patterns on the cloth
and they made their labels washable so
it could wash out
and this is just a human response
and you we're talking about new revenue
streams
but revenue is not just money it's
something called good will it's
something that
binds us as a community and
we think that it's really neat that it's
happening now but this is
just a human response that's
what's awesome now we're doing that
from an emergency standpoint and we have
an
opportunity to do that
inside the work environment too that's
what's fascinating if we can leverage
this
both as executives and managers and
as workers we can have real true
innovation it's understanding and
keeping the open mind it's it's the
age of the knowledge worker it's saying
that you know putting our ideas together
may be better than me having my way
and it's falling back on this data
analysis
this thoughtful consideration pumping
the brakes a little bit
we may not get our revenue quickly but
we're going to get our revenue more
consistently because we're creating
the community that actually accepts us
as a helpful corporation not just a
company that gives us flour
and and this i see as
a marketing trend again i was
uh i was part of a huge marketing
effort and i was talking to about 12
corporations back in 2006 and 2007
and talking about the ability
to actually say yes
we're making these things that are that
are not good for people right
our waste but we're
also taking like 90 of that
waste and converting it to things that
we can reuse and it helps us
too and it's this is this is what's
beautiful
um companies and corporations have a
unique
opportunity and guess who are
the innovators it's the knowledge worker
it's the team who knows the work and
it's the project manager
who brings the team up so once again
it this is this is not going to be a
turn on the dime activity
but it's it's actually winning the
hearts and minds
inside of the organizations and
companies
as project managers one by one
individually
and that's what we've been seeing anyway
with project managers and project
management
the dial has been going fairly positive
with embracing what project managers and
project management
really is it's not it's not the analysis
and it's not making sure we hit our
targets
it's making sure that what we're doing
meets an objective and if we can meet
that objective
better through things like goodwill why
not
that takes us to our
next poll question i think um
and this one is what project management
skills do you use in your work
and that would be what are you doing
today
project management areas are you working
with today
uh it's a pretty broad and even mix
people are doing all these different
things
various combinations
which is what you expect from a project
manager right
isn't that fascinating
right well i mean it's it's it
it's a field where you have to do some
of everything
in order to keep everything going
yes we are we are the swiss army knife
aren't we
um we have a broad range of skills and
we have to be prepared for
anything but primarily um it's the
it's the management and engagement of
people
and keeping the experts moving forward
together
isn't it so go ahead
we're looking into future
and talked about
what it looks like looking out but now
we're
we're talking about what it looks like
looking in from the perspective of the
customer the stakeholder
so when we say stakeholders it's anybody
who's impacted by my work and customer
is one subset of stakeholder
and this is the big thing
[Laughter]
i'm scared um now
that's an opportunity for us okay
there's
a type of project management called
consulting
and consulting says that if i can
solve your problem you're going to be
satisfied
so it's positioning project management
as
problem solving and if you can actually
figure out
what scares your customer
you're ahead of the game now project
management we say
we have a bunch of requirements and we
have a bunch of objectives
and i have a lot of questions for my
students and they
always ask how come my sponsor the
person who provides funding and advice
and and um decision making how come
they're not involved
because maybe what they're working on
isn't relevant to them maybe they aren't
engaged
and that's something we need to look at
now
if we go in and we help and understand
what our director and what our
supervisor and manager is scared of and
solve
that we're working on critical projects
and you
i can tell you they'll be calling you at
three o'clock in the morning
and asking how you're doing on this
problem
i'm talking about going to a
let me give you an example going to a
healthcare corporation right
and trying to understand the needs of a
director
and on the third day him just
collapsing like a balloon and say tim
that's not the real
problem you know what the real problem
is it's
i have to um accept the fact that two of
my friends are getting fired in six
weeks they're going to lose our jobs
and i'm stressed about that and at the
same time
i'm stressed that i'm going to have
three organizations i have to oversee
and i don't know how to do it i don't
have anybody who's ready to step up and
help me
and that's a problem and see
this is what we have an opportunity for
and
and we're going to see more and more and
more of that and it's obvious right
um we're we're having all of these
social and societal pressures and
stresses on us right now
and it's creating this cushion
that we've had around us for the last
two decades it says everything's fine
and everything's going to be great and
we're realizing it's not fine it's
it's not great and anything can and will
happen
and things are going to be crazier and
so
what we can do as project managers
is actually help people feel comfortable
with these i am scared conversations
like if you hear your director say
i'm mission critical that means they are
afraid that they're not
when you're when your supervisor or
manager
says i don't have time for this
that means that they if they
feel that if they take their eye off
of the work everything's gonna fall
apart and if they say
my people are smart i trust them
if they if they feel they have to
communicate that to you
that means that they're afraid they're
going to lose their brightest and best
and they don't know what they're going
to do with them so don't be afraid
to actually get into those conversations
that start getting into the humanistic
component
right now it's hard and in a lot of
business environments
like like especially uh
healthcare and the other social
businesses right
the the ones that talk about humans a
lot of things it's
it's it's almost a cultural
rule to not bring up these bad feelings
but we as project managers if we
learn how to lead and manage engage
in a way that actually allows us to
share
bad emotions as well as good emotions it
gives us an
opportunity to put things out on the
table you know it's
it's like a diabetic you know i know
what i need to do i know but i don't
want to think about it
and that's the role of a doctor a
humanistic doctor
is has an opportunity to come in and say
let's get comfortable about this because
this is reality
and if you and i can talk about reality
we can actually
solve problems not just get work
done and so as a
leader and a manager a project manager
we can actually facilitate this we we
have this
opportunity not just to lead and manage
our team but to lead and manage
engage all people around us
including our executives and including
the janitors
the janitors know so much more than
anybody
really admits and that's what our job is
and that's what leadership
is pulling all these things together
and understanding this and creating an
environment where we can actually
you know get all the cars out in the
table see what we have and solve
problems
now this means that as we
embrace this role
customers and stakeholders and sponsors
are going to actually ask us more
questions and they're going to keep us
more involved we're not going to be
behind a desk
we're not going to be staring at
spreadsheets we're going to
actually be working with people we're
going to be working with people more in
the hallways we're going to be working
with
people more in the elevators we're going
to be working over three cups of coffee
in the cafeteria
our jobs are going to look more and more
and more
like an executive manager at the same
time
we still have to be that line
manager the manager who ensures
that the work is progressing and the
people who are doing the work
don't have anything that gets in the way
the role of a project manager is
really difficult because we don't
just have line management we just don't
have teams we also have
executive management which is a strategy
in the vision
right we bring the vision to the team
we bring the image and the interest
and the engagement and the why the
reason
why the work is valuable to the
executive
and we're the ones in the middle and and
this is going to be even
more important as we move forward there
there's been a really big push in the
last seven to eight years to outsource
a lot of work right control cost control
projects especially if you can put
something in a project
and give it to an expert you're going to
get a reliable outcome
and you can control the cost more
effectively these guys do this
as their job right well
if it's mission critical it's going to
be brought in house
and if it's closer to how revenue is
made
in these extreme times both economic
as well as cultural times a lot of
businesses
are more hesitant to move that work
off site to move it outside the company
so we're going to see an opportunity for
project managers to participate
much more in mission critical
work that's what's that's what's
really interesting you know yeah we'll
do we'll still do
pilots we'll stu do uh sandbox
but we have an opportunity if we're
willing to step
up to participate in and contribute to
the major decisions of corporations
isn't that fascinating yeah
um so given that from that i take the
project management steps more front and
center
and that leads to the next question
which is
go back to that what new challenges will
project managers face as
organizations resume business as usual
so businesses of course is not business
as usual
exactly exactly
so so i'm not going to repeat what i've
said
i'm going to just add on to it primarily
we're going to step up right we're going
to step up
and the team is going to step up and the
executives are going to step up and
we're going to
take on mantles of responsibility and
accountability like we never have been
but yes it's hard but the opportunities
are incredible for us right now
problem is people being people
our stakeholders and our sponsors the
end user says
fix it now i don't want to think about
it
a lot of the problems that we're going
to have is not a fix it now problem
they're called uh dilemmas right
a dilemma is something that doesn't go
away and we're gonna have to learn how
to balance that
as we learn more and more about
leadership we need
learn how to discern between a dilemma
and an issue you can put an issue to bed
but a dilemma is going to be there for
example
um we don't have money now
to do a project we're not going to have
money in three years but the work has to
get done
that's not going away that's a dilemma
and we're going to
deal with it right and that's where
project management
can step in you know okay we're going to
talk about this
let's go ahead and talk about how this
can be done let's put our thinking caps
together
we need to transition this this is the
old
epictetus greek philosopher mindset
right
it's changing from i'm not going to tell
you what to do
i want to teach you a new way of
us gathering together and solving
problems you want to actually
have a solution this is the way to do it
right let's start making decisions
in a different way not just putting
things to bed not just giving it
somebody and checking in in five weeks
it's
actually we're gonna have to collaborate
and we're going to experience
times when we're in lockdown and not
we're going to experience a lot of times
when we have a lot of money
and we don't we're going to have
political unrest we're going to have
people moving across the planet
and we're not even talking about
volcanoes and
earthquakes and everything else that
we're talking about right now right
and there are going to be things that
are going to happen beyond this
and that's what we have to be ready for
it's the great unknown
and the beautiful thing is project
management
is a group of skills that helps you do
work that's
never been done before and as a manager
and leader if you have that on top of
that
you have an opportunity to not just have
a say
in the work you do you have a little bit
more control of your work
you're going to be working on on stuff
that's more
relevant and more important and that's
job satisfaction
and if you do this consistently it
paychecks are a uh are a you know
it's it's a foregone conclusion you
don't have to worry about that
these are the type of people that
businesses are looking for
it's the people who are willing to get
in
and be in the middle of that crucible
and to be able to facilitate the
discussions
and it's not my decision that's the best
but it's the outcome of everybody
agreeing together what's best and that's
what we're looking at
excellent yeah that was reiterating the
point that it's
it's learning how to think
so that you can think about new problems
in new ways
and if that that gets to
as you've talked about there are
stakeholders there's people who sign
your paycheck
there's people who guide your employers
business
towards growth and innovation
and these people rely
on project managers
translate strategic vision into
execution
and what expectations do they have of
project managers coming into this new
era
very good very good yes it and
and again it's setting expectations and
resetting expectations
and it's a project manager not having
their way
but a project manager facilitating the
best way and that's what we're going to
be looking at
and and it's it's our job to
set and manage expectations it may not
be
our expectations and and
here's what we're going to realize um
this is going to be a conversation topic
for the next five years at work everyone
what worked yesterday won't work today
we're going to have to reinvent the
wheel
we're going to do this constantly
constantly constantly
and we have to reset
we need to figure this out and move on
that doesn't work the the the
rapid change that we're going on drucker
and deming were talking about the
acceleration
of change and not just due to technology
um we're going to be hit with this time
and time again the next two to three
decades
and we're going to realize that
skills are going to be different work is
going to be different
but commerce and communication stand
consistent we can rely on those and
this is a real big topic everyone
um i'm i'm discussing this with a bit
a lot of cxos they
are starting to understand
i can't hire for skills i can't hire for
a certain language that somebody
writes in and compiles in i have to hire
problem solvers who can land and
understand
languages in general and be able to
select the best language or just learn a
language on the fly
and that's for uh there for uh writing
code right
but we're also talking about
construction we're also
talking about fuel and oil we're talking
about
pharmaceuticals can you imagine the
changes that our pharmacy companies have
had to
go through in the last three months to
actually
re-tool to solve this problem
and this is the way all businesses are
looking at you know how we need to
operate
as a business not just solving a problem
but
as a business as a whole and we can
expect
this is what we're going to be working
in have patience with the people around
you
have patience with the problems that
you're solving
and know that your skills and your
abilities are bringing the right people
together
to to get the best answer
this doesn't happen without everybody's
participation
and we have a unique opportunity right
now guys um
nowhere um
ever have we addressed
these great problems in society and our
entire species
where we had such access to
communication
other people other knowledge and we need
to take greater advantage of this
and that's where we as project managers
can actually do this it's the knowledge
and information management ensure that
you know we're getting the information
we're keeping people engaged both from
the management side
as well as the team side and creating
that
that opportunity for the crucible to
create the innovation everybody wants
excellent so let's move on because we've
had a marvelous discussion and before we
get to
q a let's move on to one last poll
question
and this one says looking at the same
set of skills
which ones are you most interested in
adding to your repertoire what do you
want to learn
so that you can take on more and
do water at your job talked about
the ability to be at a swiss army knife
so to speak to be
able to do a lot of different things as
part of a
project management discipline so there's
a lot of interesting skills and
and approaches that are available to
people
it goes without saying that simply learn
it's a great way for people to acquire
these
new skills and certifications but i feel
like wow
a lot of people are interested in pmp
certification
um and a lot of people are curious about
agile
with that i'm going to go
let's go ahead and go to the question
and answers
and we have a number of
questions that came in from the audience
over the course of the
webinar we have a question
are you seeing a shift in the set of
skills needed for
project managers
especially if you think in the context
of the
project management body of knowledge
um so if you look at the project
management skills their scope schedule
and cost
they are
risk quality and contracting
they are team you know resource
management
communications and stakeholder um
there's not a shift it's
a um it's a transformation in the way we
use these skills together a scope
schedule and costs are still
are still important to businesses we got
to have it now we've got to have it
cheap
and we got to have all the belts and
whistles we want what we're seeing
is a greater demand on we're in the
middle
of it and we have a new idea how do we
integrate this new idea in it
and so it's not just those skills needed
it's also being able to forecast
and to be able to get these changes
into our planning instead of in the
middle of the projects
and a lot of my students and again i
i touch hundreds of new students every
month
i've taught between 6 500 and 7 000
people now
and now in the last five or six years
the conversation is how do i actually
move
these changes into the early part
this was discussed in pmi back in 2000
and 2001 2002 can we actually
focus a lot on understand the needs and
expectations of people
and get that as early in change
management
doesn't exist to control the number of
changes in a project
the way you control the number of
changes in a project is identifying
stakeholders early and everybody will
know that from my classes if you attend
them
and it's also having to do
with managing expectations and using
something called consensus where you get
everybody to agree
so we're getting back to leadership it's
not
and it's not that leadership is new it's
that we're going to invest in it
more and more and more it's emotional
intelligence
now here's the kick
i i continue to be surprised when i look
at the definition of emotional
intelligence
it's understanding the emotions and the
emotional drivers of others
and it's also understanding and learning
how to control
my own emotions and so
learning how to be a leader is learning
how to lead yourself as well
and that's what we need to be doubling
down on right now
because if you lead yourself and you
have discipline to yourself you have
more
confidence right and all of a sudden
that confidence
gains people's trust in you and it's
it's funny
that it works that way um we need to
invest much more
in in these topics
um i've got a few questions here i'm
going to combine into
one um questions are around
digital tools one aspect being
what kinds of tools you can use in
project management
in the remote setting and
one general how digital tools will
facilitate
affect project management
so you're thinking tools are wonderful
and tools are going to constantly change
um
microsoft project that we also have p6
right primavera and we have sciforma
and they're great they have huge
databases and they allow us to collect
big sets of information right
and they allow us to do some wonderful
things
i see those as very powerful i see
collaborative tools like trello and you
can probably mention
seven or eight more that are popping up
constantly
are wonderful what i'm fascinated by
are the black swans like zoom
zoom is another tool it's communication
facilitation tool right
and and that's the thing um what i
see us in a remote
setting is actually switching
our vision from
tools to requirements
from tools to objectives all of these
tools are great but what we need to
start thinking on
is for this team how
is this team going to be most effective
how is this team going to be most
effective number one
with communicating how is this team
going to be effective number two
with sharing and transmitting data do we
need sharepoint do we need
um a shared network file
and again the tools are important but i
i i sound like a broken record and
a lot of people are turned off by this
it's
more about focusing on
this work to be getting done and
how we're going to move forward because
as soon as we have an effective tool for
another project it may not be as
effective for another
so what i really appreciate
about project management formal training
especially the pmp
they actually teach you the fundamentals
and the the analysis that all these
tools do
so you understand why these tools are
fundamentally valuable
so when you walk into a project you can
say okay this is good for this
and this works but you know what you're
going to be offline
for six hours a day so why don't we just
do this schedule analysis
in excel and we'll just do it email okay
and it's good enough for this project
and maybe that's all you need
and in agile like the burn down chart
maybe i can just share with you a
powerpoint and if you need the file
i can open up um onedrive
and have have you get access to that or
maybe you can just download
um a read-only version of it right and
so
i i don't want to say that
there are no good tools out there
they're wonderful tools and they're so
much better than they were
even a year ago but at the same time
i see our needs and expectations
as people and as groups
growing and changing so quickly that as
soon as we learn how to do a tool
we're going to find a better tool coming
up
and and so learn
what the tools do and what makes them so
special
and then use those criteria for
selecting the tools on hand
remember we're a swiss army knife we're
landed in the middle of a forest and we
have to make do with what everybody has
in their pack
that mindset is going to pull us through
in the next three to five years
and when we do have access to the 5 000
the 25 thousand dollar tools we know how
to select the best one
for all the work we're doing i know it's
a bit of a cop-out answer but it's the
best one i have
no i i thought it was a good answer
um we have a couple of questions uh with
respect to agile
and and how agile applies in the current
you know how it's affected traditional
project management but also
how it can be applied in situations
where you're managing
freelancers okay so
um agile started as a response
to software development's needs right
software development actually needs
to be fairly flexible until you hand the
software over at the end and still it's
flexible because you have beta launches
right
and that's what software development
life cycle says here's 70
percent let's you and me customer work
together
and finish it right and and that works
really well
and so we developed a whole way of doing
work
now the problem was this way of doing
work
was assumed to replace project
management
and that's the problem it was a it then
and
we get into what uh gartner calls the
hype cycle right
everybody gets excited about it and then
everybody gets disappointed
and there's gradual adoption right
we're in the gradual adoption phase of
agile
and we're learning that agile is
really good response to a lot of
different types of work like
marketing campaigns like um
deployment of new products and this kind
of thing and we can actually do that and
and agile is doing just that it's
creating the work
in such a way and it's doing the work in
such a way
that critical decisions can be made
along
as you progress and the expectation
of executives in the 80s and 90s was
agile meant
fast doesn't mean fast it means getting
the best result
and it also means the team has to step
up
and teams don't like to step up
sometimes they're they're experts
they enjoy doing the work and the
project manager has to learn how to
trust the team because the team
is going to be making more decisions and
the project manager has to tell
executives
you know you got to trust the team and
the
executive has to learn how to trust and
and this is this is why we had that
great lapse in in adoption of agile
moving forward we have a great
opportunity and this was the
impact of the sixth edition of the
project management body of knowledge
it said here's project management
and here's agile this is what agile's
really good for
and if you want to do agile here's how
it impacts your schedule
here's how it impacts risk here's how it
impacts quality
here's how it impacts engaging with your
teams and
engaging with your stakeholders so it
defined the pmbok actually was
really helpful we we worked um with the
agile consortium
and came up with a model that said
you know there are there here's how you
control the project
here's how the work gets done and here's
how
doing agile work impacts the controls
so we're going to be further and further
integrating this model into this
the project manager may not be called a
project manager in the future
but they'll still be doing the work of a
project manager they may be a product
owner they may be a scrum master
they may be a facilitator of the sprints
we don't know what they're going to be
called
but they're still going to be doing the
work controlling the budget and schedule
and scope and risk and quality
we're we're not going to talk about
project management as
a job assignment per se now again
this is this is just an opinion i have
today it may be a different opinion
when i eat dinner tonight but it may be
the project management is a role that
can be distributed across multiple
people
and we all get to be leaders don't we
yup last question
um what what's your feeling about job
opportunities
in the field as we come out of
peter drucker back in 2004 said
that uh companies are gonna uh
are no longer gonna outlast last the
career of people
and this was back in 2005. you are going
to
have to find work and find it constantly
um project managers are in a unique
situation where they're swiss
army knives right which means they're
problem solvers
which means that they're caretakers of
the things
people are scared of and concerned about
if we embrace this role we will always
have work
now it may be gig work you may be a
consultant or an entrepreneur
it may be that you're actually a line
worker
and you use your project management
skills
for continuous improvement it may be
these other things and this is this is
the key
like i said project management is a
group of skills it's not a job title
it's general management and and the
beautiful thing is
the whole spectrum of what project
management is the project management
framework is the same
material that executives go
to study in business school
you're getting a understanding of the
entire business spectrum
you're learning to think and talk as an
executive
you're learning to think and talk as an
entry level
or a line manager you're understanding
business in
in a certain way that many people don't
have an
opportunity and you can take great
advantage of this now
it's not going to be easy because a
company
is not going to give you a career you're
going to have to learn
what you're good for and what you want
to do because it's going to be 40 or 50
years and that's what i tell my students
pick something that you really enjoy and
you think you're going to enjoy doing
work for decades
number two learn how to learn keep
reinventing what you know and understand
that works what works today
doesn't work tomorrow find people like
yourself
because if you have a company of
people like you they're going to protect
your back more right
this is this is hardwired into us this
is something that's built
over forty and a hundred thousand years
this is the way human
humans think and act find your community
and then find an unmovable object
because this unmovable object is to make
you uncomfortable
it's going to make you frustrated and
it's going to continue
to force you to grow and learn
and unlearn and learn again and
work with people and this is how
you're going to retain your your
viability i started off saying
that we're not um we're
we're not worried about being taken
advantage of
now we're worried about even being
relevant and if you want to be relevant
this is the type of work that we can
expect to be
to be working on and this is what peter
drucker called
as the as the knowledge worker
not a tool worker and not a product
maker wonderful i think that's uh taken
us to the end of questions and answers
and that means it's taken us the end of
the webinar so what i'd like to do
tim is if you'd like to show people how
you can
how they can keep in touch with you um
you can find me over in linkedin if you
want
um there's there's all sorts of ways to
get hold of me through simply learn
i'm uh i'm a program advisor and also
a trainer over at simply learn so
if you reach out to support or send a q
a that way
it'll get to me i guarantee you uh but
yeah i'm i'm out on linkedin right now
thank you tim and thank everybody uh
thanks everybody for being here today
um we hope you've enjoyed this webinar
and the other webinars in our
step into the sunlight series we have
one more scheduled
one week from today on cloud computing
and devops
and that will be with matthew david a
fascinating and enlightening
webinar as this one was and
again you can also keep track of us
through our social media handles and
tags
go on tim to the next we're on facebook
we're on twitter
we're on linkedin and
we're worldwide so again we want to
thank you all
and we hope to see you next week and in
future
simply learn webinars that concludes
today's webinar we'd like you
if you would please log off of webex
thank you all and goodbye
thanks again and thank you stuart
you